well
so we start today's show
with the uh
uh
tanning testicles testicular tanning
is trending today on twitter
because tucker carlson
now feels like to be manly
to be manly he must french fry his balls
is it really that surprising
that these anti-massacre alpha cuck
tucker
are french frying their nut sacs is this
really that surprising
i mean i don't i don't know that we
should be surprised by this
i'm a man i don't have to wear a mask
but i got a
i gotta i gotta tan my balls
i'm not saying that ball tanning isn't
all that bad i mean you know
maybe if you're trying to uh attract
some of the men
that uh tucker had in his uh his little
montage you know maybe i don't know
i don't know i could see how someone
could be attracted to a
a freshly tan set of gonads
i don't know i guess i should just have
a [ __ ] list
a list
of words
synonyms that you can use
sack synonyms
oh for [ __ ] sake this is
this is the stupid [ __ ] that we have to
talk about and we're gonna talk about it
because really honestly this tucker uh
tucker carlson documentary on how
men are fading away and men aren't manly
anymore and all this [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
it's all anti-gay tropes
to be frank with you and they're trying
to make it to where non-experts are
[ __ ] experts
this [ __ ] he's trying to out joe
rogan joe rogan here
with this stupid [ __ ] documentary
about how men aren't manly or some [ __ ]
testosterone levels are low
well there's a lot of explanations for
that
oh [ __ ]
so we're going to talk about tanning
your nut sac today for crying out loud
also we have news that um alex jones and
infowars are faking being broke
i'm gonna explain why that's important
and why i think the sandy hook parents
really don't give a [ __ ] if they receive
one dime from that pile of [ __ ]
it's not about the money to them i don't
think i don't think there's any amount
of money that would replace their
children
or the [ __ ] dignity that they so well
deserve
that they were stripped from with
infowars and their defamation so we're
going to talk about alex jones
filing for bankruptcy
so that he tries to skate
on paying
his debt that he owes to the sandy hook
parents thank you mj thank you mj for
the
for the super chat she's here good
monday morning everyone um lisa's here
margie's here beth is here susan's here
everyone's here this morning paul regina
carey
welcome welcome welcome you guys know
that we broadcast live every single
weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
right here on youtube twitter twitch so
go follow us and subscribe to the
youtube channel do not forget to do that
that is super
super important because then you can
participate in the super chat
like mj did
on on on
on the tubes of you you can participate
in the super chat we also broadcast now
live every single weekday from midas
touch facebook page
thank you for all you folks out there
that are joining us from the metaverse
that is facebook
and if you want you can go download the
episodes download on apple spotify
google
even spotify even the even the best
boycotted directory
so go check us out there please
give us a five star review that would
help us out
and again go to the youtube page we're
gonna cut some clips we're gonna we're
gonna make some fun of these people so
you don't wanna miss a thing
you do not want to miss a thing i had
someone comment the other day they said
you broadcast during hal sparks show i
think i have some sparklers that come
that come and
uh listen to the show here
and they said we broadcast during the
same time the hal does i don't know that
we overlapped too much with hal but
here's the good news
is hal is recorded i'm recorded so you
can you know flip back and forth or you
can listen to us either way
i like how i was on stuttering john's
podcast and me and hal had a
conversation the other day uh it was the
day that gilbert godfrey had passed away
that they announced that he passed away
so we
we we me and hal got to talk on
stuttering john's podcast you guys
should check that out if you go to the
youtube channel and go on down to the
playlist there's a playlist
where you can actually see all the
appearances that i've made i've been on
stuttering john a few times in a few
other podcasts the bad brad berkwitch
show
the dig on america podcast a few other
you can go check those out also gabe's
got a few appearances down there as well
uh anita and lacey says they're
sparklers kelly says she's a sparkler
welcome sparklers you are welcome here
at the tony michaels podcast
broadcasting every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch
and now on the midas touch facebook page
as well we simulcast and it's free baby
all this is free
free for your viewing pleasure and
listening pleasure if you go download it
on apple or spotify
oh boy what a weekend a lot of film from
this weekend
a lot of film a lot of video a lot of
video from this weekend
from tucker carlson's
um ball tanning documentary also um
there's an airplane ride that
[Laughter]
broke out and
uh
jesus guitar
i don't know
i think
jesus would have smashed that guy's
guitar he'd have been singing in his
face you got to see this video
and let's see what else what else what
other videos
we're uh trending this weekend
there's a lot of stuff that came from
this weekend
uh let's see i get i get what what do we
got on the the agenda today
let's see we get that oh elizabeth
warren wants to investigate jared
kushner that's a good one uh mexican
pizza is trending i'm not sure why i
don't know why mexican pizza is trending
but it sounds like a hell of a trending
topic to me so we might get into that
when we go surf the tweety tweets and
eternity trends today you know that's
what we do on the show for all the new
listeners out there we do a thing called
the [ __ ] list roundup where we round up
all the tweety tweets and eternity
trends of the day
and today it looks like we may go
through testicle tanning and mexican
pizza
i i don't know what to tell you i don't
make this [ __ ] up
i just get up in the morning i see
what's trending i put it on there and
then i go through right i have no idea
why
mexican pizza is trending but we're
gonna we're gonna talk about it
uh common core is trending uh as a
german it seems like um
the right wingers are
our little butt hurt that someone got as
a german trending
but but the main news today is that it's
tax day it's it's tax day it's testy day
and it's alex jones is pretending to be
broke day
so let's go ahead and get into the
trendy trends
and the tweety tweets
uh
let's get let's get into that
so let's let's go to
let's go to the timeline i want to i
want to see the timeline
now it looks like
where's my
where is my trendy trends in tweety
tweets video someone took it off here
i don't have it
i don't have it i'm really sorry i wish
i had i wish i had it okay let's
let's see
um
of course you know that alex jones is
pretending to be broke
but the main thing is is also
republicans out there not only they oh
well we're in the wrong one here we go
this is a bitter one there we go now
we're cooking
now we're cooking let's make this a
little bigger so you can see the tweety
tweets um uh joe says it's my kinda
uh
i'm kind of surprised republicans are
banning
matt textbooks i thought division was
their thing
so you heard this you heard this this is
also news that the republicans in
florida are trying to ban crt from
macbooks
what in the actual [ __ ]
they're tr i'm serious dead [ __ ]
serious
they're trying to sexualize your
children's gender they want to marry him
and now and now they want to racialize
math well
two plus two isn't four
two plus two is the race card what the
[ __ ] are they talking about
jesus christ they're trying to bend to
kill a mockingbird
and they're trying to ban long division
what in the [ __ ] are they doing
how in the [ __ ] is it
that we think we can't beat these
[ __ ]
democrats everywhere should be yelling
and screaming the messaging into the
microphone
everywhere i don't care if you're you're
a candidate if you're working for a
candidate if you're knocking doors if
you're filling out postcards this is
easy messaging folks
like
these [ __ ] boneheads are gonna be so
easy to beat
why do we have to [ __ ] work so
goddamn hard to get people to understand
the messaging why why and everyone wants
to blame it on democrats on the hill
it's not just democrats on the hill
there are people out there yelling and
screaming about medicare for all
and and canceling student debt listen if
you let the [ __ ] that are
trying to make your math books into
critical race theory you're not gonna
cancel any student debt you'll be lucky
that there will be a college to even go
to
got it
they don't even want you to have a
college to go to
think about it think about it
we got the messaging right here in our
right here at our fingertips in
tennessee they're trying to they're
trying to marry children
all over the country they're stripping
women's liberty away from getting a
medical
making medical decisions and getting a
medical procedure making it a felony
i mean the intention is to destroy roe v
wade
and all the while while they destroy roe
v wade they strip your liberty away from
you
your choice over your body
they want it not you they want to take
your consent away they want to take your
freedom away they want to take your
rights away they want to take your
liberty away
they keep sexualizing your children's
gender it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] weird
that they're absolutely obsessed with
genitals they're [ __ ] obsessed even
tucker carlson is doing a documentary on
how he's gonna [ __ ] tan his testies
so he can be a man they're [ __ ]
obsessed with testicles and genitalia
closeted [ __ ]
they are it has to be it has to be
they're so obsessed with dicks and balls
they are obsessed with it
they can't stand it
they want to take your consent away from
you with your children doubt me
in state after state after state they're
taking they're taking parent parental
consent away
from just a few trans athletes
in schools children trans children who
want to be at least they're taking their
parents consent away from them
you don't and they want to marry
children you don't think that's the next
consent step
we have it all at our fingertips here
folks
it's really easy the messaging is really
easy and we don't need to run against
each other
democrats don't have to run against
democrats it's not a thing that we have
to do
even in the primaries
why can't we understand how this [ __ ]
works
there's two things in this country two
there's politics and there's government
you wanna govern you gotta do the
politics thing you gotta win elections
and let me tell you something folks i
hate to i hate to be the [ __ ] buzz
kill here but no one's going to go
crawl over hot lava
and vote at the polls because some
people want to cancel their student debt
not going to happen it's not going to
happen you can talk and yap all [ __ ]
day you want
and try to convince me
it's not gonna happen
you're not going to mobilize the entire
country because some people want to
cancel student debt it's not a thing i
want to cancel student debt i don't
think we should have student debt i
don't think we should
i don't think people should have to i
don't i really think we should have a a
a higher education system past high
school that is publicly funded full stop
but you aren't going to have that from
the people who want to ban map books
because the crt
the messaging is there
we don't have to [ __ ] run against
each other and i mean what i mean is
pro-democracy people pro-democracy
people do not have to stand and fight
how much student debt they want to
cancel and when they want to do it and
how they want to do it [ __ ] that [ __ ] we
do not have to run against each other
we do not
all's you have to do
all you have to do
is go
go fight them on the hill they want to
die on they want to die on taking
people's liberty away in this country
and do it by being weirdly obsessed with
children's gender
people's sexuality and who they love
they're [ __ ] weirdos
you want the people who are sexualizing
your gender and talking about tanning
testicles in charge of your gas prices
you want people who are trying to marry
your children in tennessee
in charge of our supply chains like greg
abbott isn't supply is in charge of the
supply chain in texas he can't pluck his
head out of his ass long enough to
understand that he has now cost the
state of texas not just the money that
it took to stop up the supply chain
but now the amount of money that it
takes
to get the supply chain back
doubt me let's let's go look at a video
here i'm going to show you
a report from texas this isn't difficult
i know you want to talk about testes and
alex jones
but you're gonna have to blame greg
abbott for this chris had this posted
it's a video
uh from a report from from texas let's
watch it real quick
brothers produce is racing to fill
orders we sell hundreds of thousands of
cases every week as texans brace for
impact a lot of times we buy things in
mexico because it's good quality it's
convenient it's fast we can get things
overnight time is of the essence when it
comes to fresh produce we try to turn
our inventory every two to three days i
mean we're selling a dying product that
the second it's picked
we need it within three four days
because we got to get that to the
consumers and these products are going
to cost the farmers a lot of money
truckers a lot of labor and ultimately a
lot of food waste is going to come out
of this brothers produce delivers to
retirement homes stadiums schools
grocery stores and restaurants and this
is private business by the way
this isn't some kind of socialist commie
radical
government-owned company this is private
[ __ ] industry
and greg abbott is pissing them the [ __ ]
off
you talk about supply chain and and oh
empty shells biting bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] the biden administration worked
their balls off
i don't know if they're tanned balls or
not
i don't know if they're testiculars
or spray tanned but they worked their
asses off to get the supply chains fixed
after trump and the trump administration
destroyed our economy and our supply
chains with the pandemic and their trade
policies and here you have an easy
solution for this private industry
private industry produce in texas
and greg abbott says nope
for this for the sake for the sake of a
manufactured crisis
for the sake of a manufactured crisis
we're going to stop up the produce
supply chains so we have empty shells in
the grocery stores well how [ __ ] how
[ __ ] superb of him
now
it's all about us
it's up to us to message this to get
this word out that the reason why your
[ __ ] shelves are empty you don't have
strawberries is because that fascist
down in texas greg abbott is stopping
them at the border and spoiling your
strawberries that you want to eat
because he wants to manufacture a crisis
to scare you
about mexicans
doubt me
oh it's a crisis at the border border
border border border border border
border border border they can't stop
talking about the border and what they
should be doing
is making sure that that produce
gets back into our country so we can
sell it so these private companies can
make all that profit
it's really [ __ ] ridiculous
that we can't figure out this messaging
folks
it's really simple
it's really simple beto gets it
better gets it how do you why do you
think greg abbott rescinded his policy
about the trucks on the border
he rescinded his policy because bet
o'rourke
was handing him his ass on social media
and pointing out that he was trying that
greg abbott was intentionally emptying
shells in grocery stores
and greg abbott did not want texans to
know that because greg abbott probably
will have to run against beto and the
general
did it do here you go here's sarah
burris
thanks greg abbott see she gets it
sarah gets it
that's how you do this
hey we need to have a sticker for the
strawberries and blueberries and
blackberries and the produce
for the empty shelves at the grocery
store
empty shelves greg abbott did that
let's see
now we're 21 minutes into the hour i
think i think someone's going to be
joining us at the bottom of the hour to
talk about um
to talk about
uh testicular tanning
the science behind it and rather it's
[ __ ] relevant or not
uh cynthia thank you very much for the
super sticker
we appreciate it a lot thank you for the
support um you know it's easter weekend
there's a couple things i want to show
before we get the uh
the testicular tanning expert on um
here's a video from a parade uh fifty
shades away and posted this
look at this what the [ __ ]
this is literally a parade and they're
nailing they're nailing jesus to the
cross here
and then they're crying yelling and
screaming
oh my god
happy easter oh
[ __ ] these yeah these people i tell you
what you just can't make this [ __ ] up
can you
you just can't make this [ __ ] up now i'm
going to show you another video here
apparently
um people are freaking out about this
video
here it is i said oh my jesus
this thing's got 33 million views
33 million views this video has
oh my god so i guess i guess they get on
a [ __ ] plane
and you know you're kind of trapped in
the air with a bunch of people when
you're on a [ __ ] plane you're 30 000
feet here i mean
there's not a lot of things that might
be worth jumping out of a plane without
a parachute this might be one of them
this this what you're about to see might
be on the list of things that you would
jump out of an airplane without a
parachute for
right here
and the the
the caption says worshipping jesus 30
000 feet in the air now what i want you
to pay attention to
if you can see my mouse here see this
guy right right down here
see this right here
um for uh he's he's in he's in the um
he's in the he's in the plaid shirt here
watch his face because this guy's
playing the guitar
like right in his face let's see
[Music]
you see his face he's not happy at all
like this guy here in the middle with
the plaid shirt on he is not happy that
this guy is playing this [ __ ] guitar
right in his face
oh my god
[Music]
and this person pans over to the window
like oh i wish i could just jump out
this window i wish i could just jump out
this window
it really is kind of
[ __ ] weird that they would um decide
that it was a good idea to entertain
everybody against their will
on a [ __ ] plane
to spread the spread the love of jesus i
guess
oh my god these [ __ ] christians don't
get it you know you you can have your
christianity right you have your right
to be christian and
love songs and all kinds of [ __ ] right
you can sing along you can strum the
guitar and
sing your lovely easter christian songs
all you want
it's your freedom
listen
listen no one wants to be subjected
no one no one wants to be handcuffed on
a plane and listen to you sing your
[ __ ] [ __ ]
they don't
they don't
i mean
omar is trending representative omar's
training this morning because basically
let's let's go to there let me show you
why she's trending what she said because
this is relevant here
she's seen that here's the new york
daily news
she saw the video the christians singing
on the plane she then asked the
questions on social media what would
happen if muslims did the same thing
right
what would happen
what the [ __ ] would happen if muslims
stood up and started singing or praying
on a plane
people would freak the [ __ ] out
that guy that was in the plaid shirt
that was annoyed because
he wanted to smash
the guitar over the guy's head let's
face it the guy in the plaid shirt
that's annoyed as [ __ ] he wanted to grab
the guitar from that guy and just smash
it over his head that was the look on
his face the i want to smash this
guitars
on this guy's head that was the look
but she's right what would happen if
muslims would do this what would the
video entail
hmm turd in the toilet says
christians on a plane
i'm tired of these [ __ ]
christians on this [ __ ] plane i
don't know
i guess that's what you're looking for
turd
oh boy oh boy
oh
boy
let's go to tweet tweets and trendy
trends and we're gonna have our uh our
local testicular
tanning expert um here soon
i'm sure
today is tax day individual income tax
returns are due to be submitted by the
federal government
today's government day today's
oppression day today's the day that rich
people pay taxes
and they're [ __ ] pissed off about it
you know
uh i i don't know if
you know
people know this but if you got a tax
problem like really a really heavy tax
problem like you owe a shitload of money
in taxes
that's that's actually like you know
i don't know let's say you made 750 800
000 in a year and you have you owe a
shitload of taxes
you're like god damn it taking off my
[ __ ] money well listen
listen
the tax problem
isn't your problem you got a budget
problem dumb [ __ ]
you got a you got a budget problem it's
probably what you got
not a not a tax issue it's a budget
problem
whoosh
snakes on a plane too crystal says i
don't know i don't know maybe maybe they
make a movie christian's on a plane to
spoof snakes not can you spoof snakes on
a plane
i don't know i i bet you i bet we could
get uh samuel jackson to do christians
on a plane
almost bet
almost bet we could do
get the samuel l jackson to do
christians on the plane
okay let's go see why mexican pizza is
trending i'm not sure why
i just seen that it's trending and i'm
like oh we're gonna put that on the list
we're gonna um let's see
what is this
we brought
mexican pizza back
what is this
dosiacat is this that
where is this is this coachella
yeah it looks like it
we finally did it the mexican pizza is
coming back 519 taco bell oh jesus
christ did taco bell
did taco bell get product placement on
the stage at coachella is that the
[ __ ] thing here is that what's going
on what in the actual let's listen
[Applause]
she brought back the mexican pizza by
the way
no [ __ ] way is that really
is that what this is
[Music]
oh taco bell use
sons of [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
oh my god
oh they got they got product placement
on the stage at coachella that's what
this is right
that's gotta be what this is i think
that's what this is uh
it looks like taco bell got her to say
on stage that she's bringing that she
brought the mexican pizza back at
coachella yes that's what's happening
here oh jesus [ __ ] christ
we're screwed folks we are absolutely
[ __ ] screwed
we are screwed
i'm just saying [ __ ] mexican pizza's
trending because taco bell got a got a
product placement on coachella stage
everyone's freaking out that alex jones
is using chapter 11 to hide his [ __ ]
assets
we got christians on a plane
and we got [ __ ]
florida
republicans these republican kid
diddlers these pedocons in florida
trying to ban math textbooks
what in the actual [ __ ]
oh for [ __ ] sake
it's going to hell in a handbasket on
this monday
oh quick and fast and hurry let's get to
the alex jones thing now rolling stone
has this article infowars files for
bankruptcy as sandy hook lawsuits bleed
alex jones dry
a lot of people are like oh he's just
trying to hide his assets
whatever he's trying to pretend to be
broke which that's literally what he's
doing to the court so what he's telling
the court
is that i have a debtor and the debtor
has a judgment against me in the court
and i can't pay that debt now judge
and bankruptcy court i do have i do have
on one hand i do have a profitable
business model
that i could structure the payments of
that debt and that's really what they're
doing with chapter 11 wait a second wait
a second wait a second here
um let me see i think we have um i think
we have someone here i think our i think
our testicular expert
is joining us
um let's see
um
howdy sir hey what's going on yeah uh
looks like you got a red info red light
going on there or something yeah you
know
just gotta
keep the old t levels high you know what
i'm saying oh the t levels it's just
that i i i'm guessing you're uh tanning
your testiculars is that what you're
those you're doing am i not
tanning your test so do you constantly
tan your testes listen uh every waking
minute of my day is taken up by
maximizing the amount of testosterone i
can put into my body okay i am an alpha
male yeah and i'm going to make sure
that i am
always an alpha male yep it's so
you look you look really alpha this
morning um with the uh red light shining
up on your face
it's okay you know i understand that
some betas wouldn't really get it but uh
when you're at my level of alpha right
my level of testosterone my level of
manliness
you know i what i understood about the
cause i'm i'm guessing that you're
you're taking you're heeding the advice
of tucker carlson's documentary on uh
on uh sunning your ball sack is it is
that what i take is it is that the take
i'm getting here i mean you know it's
it's more or less uh
the advice that i gave him you know oh
so you so you were you were providing
the expert advice on um yes on how the
we're doing some we're doing some really
innovative revolutionary things that are
happening on uh
on red light
oh okay i see so tell me about tell me
about um red lighting your gonads how
this makes you more of a man i'm not
sure how this works well you know i see
a lot of betas uh you know up late
gaming away
you know point dexter is really uh
staying up late using that blue light
and what does the blue light do the blue
light really brings down your
testosterone levels okay really you know
the b in blue really stands for beta
okay oh i see it's not gonna be democrat
so the blue light the blue light is like
a
it's like a democrat thing the red light
is like a red pill uh right wing type
thing i'm not saying that you get woke
from using red light but you get pretty
woke oh by woke i mean you wake up to
the reality that's around you all right
what what is the reality about your
gonads that you have to red light them
i mean uh it's really just waking up to
the god-given greek roman
just muscular man that we were meant to
be okay you know just wrestling skin to
skin man to man
bro to bro you know okay so so what
you're saying is is that that you get
naked and you tan your sack and then you
wrestle each other once your sacks are
tan i mean
essentially yeah oh okay that sounds uh
very
manly
it is right have you ever wrestled a man
not not not after i've stand my sack no
i am you know now i have a really beta
well that could be so let me ask you let
me ask you alpha cuck uh dr alpha cuck
here let me ask you if
if you tan your sack because i'm really
confused by this
because
um
if if your goal is to be more manly
right to uh i don't know spread your
seed throughout the earth
wouldn't it
very well wouldn't microwaving yours
your your gonads uh reduce your sperm
count or how does this work
look i don't expect a non-uh medical
professional to understand the sciences
behind this technology because it's
pretty advanced i'm sure it is i'm sure
it is but look look look look what i
will say is
using
red light therapy
has
an immense amount of benefits to it okay
you know you're treating any skin
conditions any rashes you may have you
know don't want to get a shot of some
sort it's natural immunity that goes
into your body straight to the
mitochondria straight into the cell now
when it comes to your privates you know
as you put it your your gonads yeah
that's a direct shot of testosterone
it's like if you put 17
shots of testosterone like you went you
went in and you wanted to get you know
added testosterone because you were you
were low in levels this is all natural
no jab
straight to the balls
yeah it's it's really not surprising
that uh anti-jab uh anti-master types
like you
are microwaving their their nutsex it's
not really surprising that they're
french frying their balls um so so let's
let's talk about the the the other the
kind of this the sausage in the room
because
to me when you're um tanning your your
sack as it were
yeah i mean well it's not tanning it's
therapizing okay what is it what are you
doing
therapizing your testicles yes
it's so it's like a testy it's
testicular therapy so it's almost like a
test drive a testy festive for yeah is
that it attached again
it's clear that a beta like yourself
wouldn't really understand the nuances
of uh testicular tanning i'm just i'm
just trying to make sure it's hip you
know maybe you should get like a strobe
light that kind of you know strobes as
opposed to just one red light that seems
to be pretty unsafe for people who have
uh yeah any sort of uh light sensitivity
you know oh okay okay so you're
sensitive i'm the doctor here and i'm
telling you right now that people do
have
light
uh sensitivities and i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna put their their health at risk
by putting flashing lights this isn't
some sort of techno dance club where you
just drop acid and just
blow whistles and
swing around uh glow sticks
you think do you think this is a joke uh
yeah we're saving lives i'm saving i am
saving lives so so do you ever naturally
tan your sack like i i don't know you
layoutings are very dangerous okay okay
so so why does uva uvb you know you just
gotta go straight to the red light oh
okay so you gotta you can't blue light
it you can't sunlight no no no it's like
the song turn on the red light you know
that song no i don't know that song can
you uh give us a
that's all that i remember from the
stuff
okay it goes turn on the red light is
that why you wear those glasses every
day is that where you wear those glasses
to protect your eyes because obviously
you know you can't protect your nuts you
got to make sure your nuts have enough
testosterone well see i gotta protect
your eyes right the eye protects the red
light is direct you know for me it's not
so much for the red light on my yellow
sunglasses the yellow sunglasses are an
anti-blue light an anti-beta light oh
okay so they blocked they blocked the
libtard um
testosterone levels that make you drop
it's like uh it's like in that movie
uh they live he puts on the sunglasses
and realizes oh the reality that's
beyond you know and with these
sunglasses right here it helps wake me
up to the reality that's around you know
so livestream media in other places you
know you got these quack doctors saying
you should get a coverage shot right
these so where did you get your degree
from doc what what what what um what
level of expertise do you hold
uh i got it from herverd university
herbert what was that
herbert university herverd what is
hervard it's like a
look how do you how do you how do you
spell herbert i i can't how do you spell
it it sounds like you're trying to say
harvard but you're saying herbert it's
herbert it's a cousin school of harvard
it's a cousin huh yeah it's like twice
removed but it's a cousin school like
this is like cousin school down in
arkansas or something or i am
in alabama oh okay alabama well yeah
they got a great great great great great
program over there i had her
herbert
we're doing some very
very
innovative uh things down there you know
i was very i was
down there down down there yes indeed
down there and i was uh very um
privileged and grateful to be part of
the program you know i actually
graduated uh
top of my class oh okay what do they
call that down there at uh herbert when
you graduate to the top of your class
is that
well they they said it was summa come
loud
summa [ __ ] loud oh okay well that's you
know that's what they wrote down on my
uh my uh diploma
summa zuma come loud okay well you know
that
i guess i i guess that could happen down
there pervert in alabama uh so when are
you gonna make a joke it's a real place
i know i i'm i'm tr i'm i'm trying not
to i came on the show to talk about red
light therapy right you know i figured i
would give you uh i'm literally giving
you a hands-on demonstration right now a
rather hands-off demonstration okay yeah
so have you washed your hands this
morning do you the red light actually
the red light uh works as a sanitization
uh tool yeah okay so basically with the
red light you don't have to take showers
so so let me ask you let me ask you
because you know as a guy who does not
red light his balls i don't tan my balls
i know that's unfortunate that sounds
pretty unfortunate for you yeah
certainly it certainly is a problem that
i don't have um i'm just thinking though
as i think about the logistics of
tanning you know a guy's sack
um that you know you would have to do
something you know to loop up the the
old uh sausage because there's you know
you got um you got a few things going on
down there not just reset right so i'm
trying to figure that out i will say you
know of all the things you've asked so
far that's actually the best uh actual
like question you've had okay so could
you elaborate what um
what what a guy would do if he was gonna
detangle right as well i mean here look
let's think of it like this you know if
you if you were to go out
into the sun you know you put sunscreen
or suntan lotion you're not just going
to go straight skinned to the grill you
know you're not going to just heat it up
and burn yourself because that would
just be idiotic and not safe now what
you got to do
is it's a combination between coconut
oil okay coconut oil
avocado oil these are two oils that have
high
burning
temperature rates you know so you can
put them in a high high degree on the
pan if you want to cook something up
they are uh they you know they're better
than grape seed oil they're better than
sunflower seed oil or better than olive
oil okay you want to use a combination
of that plus a little bit of a generic
walgreens lubriderm it's not aluminum
you don't have to go store it you have
to go name brand you just have to get a
generic walgreens brand i find that that
has the best uh lotion to water
viscosity uh ratio there now if you were
to put all three of those together it's
a it's a quick one one one ratio okay
one to one to one very simple for your
viewers out there who want to listen
just understand it's very simple you can
get it yourself from you know you
probably buy all three from a walgreens
honestly
but what you want to do is you want to
mix those together you want to put it
into the freezer
okay and you want to keep that for about
30 minutes now and now you just got to
watch it because there's going to be a
there's going to be a
top layer that is on the uh
uh on the top of what you've done okay
you want to scrape that off and that is
what you want to use
so so you want a little bit it's only a
little bit but remember it's a
combination of of avocado oil
coconut oil
and a store brand lotion uh very similar
to
uh lubriderm but not name brand lubridem
okay so when you're so when you're when
you're toasting your avocados
um
do you dip them in the fryer or i'm not
real sure i you know it looks like it
looks like what you have on your balls
is a space heater not really a infrared
it does provide heat it does keep you
warm in cold conditions you know you
know the balls are uh are one of the
areas that actually is very sensitive to
temperature and it can actually regulate
your whole body yeah
right
i understand most
most that's why if you saw this
documentary they were they were
completely naked
with only that and that shows you how
powerful the human body is you know if
you're straight pushing testosterone
into the body okay the whole especially
through through the
through your mid-range uh
you're able to warm up the whole body
it's actually pretty amazing what the
body can do from a from a medical
standpoint you know scientifically
speaking so let me ask you dr nutsec let
me ask you
um
if this truly is a problem this low t
thing because to be honest with you the
tucker carlson documentary really seems
like uh just an avenue to make sure that
the american people know that hey
uh non-experts you should look at them
as experts kind of like you who got your
your your cracker jack degree from
herbert university a great place to
class
herbert balsack red lighting degree um
it seems like the documentary with
tucker carlson really is just a ruse to
uh not only to you know spew out
anti-gay hate uh tropes and hate um but
to also make it to where people like you
seem to be experts but don't know a
[ __ ] thing is it is that am i right
in that alley am i am i probably are you
claiming that this is all just a rouge
uh
well i mean i don't know are you are you
saying that my medical degree from
herverd university and all the all of
the testing and in studies that i've
done and actually sat over on
my own board you're saying that this is
all just made up you're saying that i'm
just in it for the grift and that's what
tucker carlson is doing yeah that's
that's exactly what i'm saying uh and i
guess my next question would be is when
are you booked to go on the joe rogan
podcast because i figure that's probably
your next step is to uh go on joe rogan
you know
to answer your first question um
i don't want to speak for tucker uh it
seems pretty genuine you know we do i
wouldn't want to speak for tucker or to
tucker either but yeah go ahead you know
i i we didn't um what i will say this is
uh we did a a treatment therapy together
okay
uh you know together yeah we embraced it
was great it was wonderful you know we
had uh see
see you tan your balls together is that
how you do it i don't know i uh well
you're uh what do you think we're
savages we're using two different uh
lights that are reflecting the opposite
way
so you stand face to face we're never
touching really and you know we're not
touching in that way i mean get your
mind out of the gutter we are embracing
trying to figure it out wholeheartedly
with our arms and our chest oh okay so
you are you are
touching in that sense
oh okay okay so what about my second
question all right are you going to
experiment with joe rogan
what i will say is uh
on that circuit there's a lot of people
that i'm actually uh in communication
with right now joe rogan is one of the
people that i am planning a session to
go on his show
the other
is i'm actually talking to a few other
people uh elon musk we're talking about
adapting a uh
a
testicle tanning feature in the new
tesla model so wait wait wait it's going
to be a tesla
testicle tanning feature is it what
you're saying that's right yep
tesla testicle tanning trademark pending
uh we're working together on that well
um so basically while you're driving you
can be treating
uh yourself for low t levels you know
we're putting the the t in tesla and now
is testosterone
so so really
since you're getting so um intuitive
with the test tesla testicle tanner
how much of a problem is this really and
really is it only affecting um
republican men because it seems like
only conservative republican men are
really concerned about finding new ways
to
tan their balls so they have
a higher testosterone level when they
could do i i don't know they could take
things like testosterone it really seems
kind of like we've established from the
pandemic
no jab for me okay
no jab
just just avoid it just so you want to
get away from so even if you knew that
it was testosterone in the in you would
not take the disc you know because
here's the thing it's like uh
there are rumors many people are saying
i don't want to say it's me or but i
will say this that uh
there are these
you know they they talk about with the
vaccines but there are these microchips
these little nanobites that are in there
you know and they and they uh basically
put themselves in the testosterone now
if you were to then go to the doctor and
say hey listen i have low t levels i
want to get treated for testosterone
they say great let me
brick you with the jab now here's the
thing that people don't realize once
they jab you
those little little nano bites those
little little little micro chips that
are in there
they're going to turn from testosterone
to estrogen and why would they turn from
testosterone to estrogen why would they
do that
because it's all it's all uh it's it's
all a plan from the from the democrats
the deep state they're they're they're
coming after people you know they're
trying they're trying to make you
submissive and as an alpha male you have
to stand up you have to tell people who
you are and what you stand for and you
say i stand for testosterone i don't
stand for that
so let me
so if you stand for testosterone because
it sounds like you're really uh
referring to a medical problem which uh
some men some men actually
have a lower testosterone level and
right red light is the cure remember
well turn on the red light yeah yeah
i know that i know you know the one
we're uh lying to that song that's all
that matters here's the thing is women
you know that women have testosterone
too right you know that that's a thing
um
you know that they yeah women women
actually have a level of testosterone
did you know that
that that that testosterone is just a
hormone you know that
right no
that's that testosterone high higher low
levels of testosterone don't keep you uh
i don't know being like a responsible
person or a good father or a good
partner or or even someone who would
love someone no no that's not true
that's not true women don't have
testosterone that that's not true that
is not true i
am
yeah see see that's the thing is i i
understand that that's not what we
learned at herverd university uh well i
understand that your degree at herver
did not provide you i don't know like um
facts but the fact is is that men have
estrogen and women have testosterone no
we don't yeah only the betas have
estrogen real men have 100
testosterone and this red light actually
pushes the bounds of what's humanly
known for mankind and what is possible
with testosterone so what would happen
what would happen what do you surmise
would happen if a woman used this red
light on her i don't know used it on her
lady parts what do you think would
happen do you think do you think
something magical would happen and she
her testosterone levels would increase
the testosterone levels that she has do
you think by tanning her genitals that
would happen because a lot of women
believe it or not i don't know if you
know this
a lot of women actually tan
in a tanning bed which is not so similar
but kind of similar to you tanning your
balls with a red light you understand
that because women do that they don't
get quote unquote
manlier you know that right well because
they're not using red lights silly
they're using yellow lights
oh oh so or sometimes they use just uh
blue light that's straight from a
fluorescent tube so that's what makes
you know again
pushing the estrogen and the beta level
man
that people are trying to be you know i
know i
go ahead go ahead no i'm just saying red
light is the best you know i'm not
saying that red lights matter but they
matter oh so red lights red lights
matter they may matter
oh jesus so so did i surprise you to the
fact that women actually have a level of
testosterone i'm going to dispute that
fact i need to see uh what your research
is okay i need to see yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna i can prove you
wrong i can go i'm gonna i'm gonna go
to back to herbert university i'm gonna
speak with my actual professors and who
is your professor who was your professor
down there at the herbert university
what are you trying to dox them now oh
no i'm just i'm just saying that there's
an incredible
game i'm not going to play into this
game it sounds like you're trying to get
personal information private information
about my professors and then try to use
that in some
democratic liberal
manipulative way
if if it is really a university then
they would probably list on their
website um
who their professors are so i mean you
know you just use the process of
you know elimination and you would
figure out who the red light testicle
team well you know what if people if
people you know didn't trust me then you
know again why am i in communication
with people like joe rogan yeah
uh elon musk
uh uh alex jones is another one does
alex jones tan his nutsack he's an
investor in my company oh okay so is
that why he's filing bankruptcy because
he kind of kind of went south with the
red nutting thing the red light nut sack
thing
i mean i've received
plenty of money from him i don't see any
financial issues that i know of i'm not
too privy on the whole bankruptcy
situation right but i can tell you from
my own personal experience alex jones is
a great advocate you know he's actually
a pretty good affiliate in terms of
getting people to sign up
to to to tan their nut sex
so um you know some other names that
come to mind that that people like alex
jones and they're kind of in the same uh
red light district as you would put it
um
you know what that's actually not a bad
uh label you know maybe i should maybe i
should make a an area where where you
come you come and you get treated in the
red light district huh
i think that would i i think that could
be sure you know what i'm going to use
that uh i'm not going to pay you for the
idea i'm not going to use that okay you
can have the idea yeah come to the red
light district to the red light to get
your treatment you know
well
so there are a couple other uh [ __ ]
that are that remind me of this red
light district there's a guy named roger
stone he's real good friends with that
oh roger yeah roger's a good guy yeah
he's a customer is he also an investor
he's just a customer no no he's uh not
not an investor but he's you know if i
had to put out there a number one
customer roger stone is a is a great guy
you know
the t levels on that man are off the
chart honestly like
you know i we just did a we just did a
six-month uh kind of test to see where
he was you know a test for the test
and i got to tell you right now that boy
uh
he was greater than a hundred percent
didn't think it was possible but i'm
going to be using him for a new case
study and i'm going to submit for the uh
approval from uh herbert university so
so what you're saying is roger roger
fries his stones is that what you're
saying
is roger fries his stones with avocado i
wouldn't say he fries them but again you
know honestly tony i should be hiring
you for my marketing i mean you know
we've got red light district we've got
uh rogers you know stone stones you know
i'm not going to say it's completely
accurate but i see where you're going
with it okay well you know i wasn't here
i wasn't really bought into you when i
first arrived you know you seemed very
much like a skeptic however i see i feel
like i'm turning you around you know
going absolute or red well you didn't
give me the red pill you showed me the
red light so one last person that i'd
like to ask about if they're a customer
not because i'm not sure that they're
into the red light thing and tan and
their balls uh it's a guy who likes
spray tan a lot it really seems like rub
on spray tan i'm wondering if um if if
there's a if artificial tanning your
balls if that has the same effect as the
red light which is no effect probably um
on your testosterone levels so can you
spray tan your balls like the cheeto
dust mobster donald trump would spray
tan his face is there is there a theory
that you have where if you uh have an
artificial tanner on your nut sack if
that would uh right that'll cause cancer
what would cause cancer uh
listen there's only one way to properly
treat testosterone okay it is the only
one so there's only one way it's the red
light now if you're spray tanning here's
the thing what i will say is uh donald
trump for
you know all of the craziness there
donald trump's actually a true beta okay
i'll i'll tell you that right now he's
not actually now you're really putting
yourself out there i am but you know
what i mean for the amount of money i've
made off this little red light here on
people's balls uh helping them with
their testosterone
i've got a whole whole war chest but i
can tell you this much that man donald
trump
he's a true beta
and uh yes i know there have been rumors
of him uh artificially you know
treating his balls with uh with spray
tan yeah and what i can tell you is
spraying
you know red spray paint on your
genitals is not the same thing okay
okay
that's that is what i've heard um you
know i i heard uh that's what he did and
people
uh you know were asking inquiring me for
my medical advice my professional
medical advice you know coming to me and
saying you know as the student of
harvard university you know summa come
loud they want to know
um
how you know is this the same thing and
i know no only an idiot would spray tan
spray tan as balls with uh
with with red
uh acrylic spray paint right um
so your balls turn red when you red
light them because i i figured it'd just
tan no no they don't they don't turn red
that's the thing you know i i i don't
know where uh donald trump got that idea
that spray painting was the same effect
as
this this tan
uh this treatment of testosterone but i
can tell you for a fact you know i've
seen some photos um for you know people
who shall remain unnamed uh in terms of
inquiring about how to deal with this
and i can tell you right now
that uh
he's
you know he's trying to fake it you know
he's uh the estrogen levels the beta
levels on that man are incredibly high
and uh
i'm sorry to say but he's not a true
alpha and well definitely not uh
definitely not doing what he should be
doing i don't doubt that he's not he's
not an albert i don't doubt that he's
not a beta and i think it has nothing to
do with what he's spraying on his balls
or doing with his balls i mean i would
say that he's going to get cancer from
spraying his balls with red spray paint
but that's
that's just my medical opinion and my
accent i'm sure
yeah i'm sure your your medical opinion
is worth a lot
uh coming from uh suda come loud is that
what you said sue to come around from
herbert university down there
from herbert university top of my class
alabama well thank you dr nutsac we
appreciate you joining us today is it dr
nutsac is that is that what you go by
red sex or what's the doctor newt sock
oh dr nuked suck okay
it's uh it's european okay i got you so
the european uh fake doctor that got his
degree from herbert university down
alabama real doctor
wheelchair
lounge results um whose best customers
is alex jones uh and roger stone and
elon musk thank you doctor for joining
us and
time giving us that riveting information
on uh red lighting your balls um i i
wish the best of frying to you sir and
you have a good day and let me know if
you're uh if your audience wants a
discount just i'd be afraid of people
we don't need a promo code we don't need
a promo code for them but i'll make a
new one right now it'll call b red light
district if you want to call if you want
to go to dr newt sock dot com
slash
red dash light
uh go to that website and enter the
discount code i'll make it right now
after i get out this interview um
uh red light district you know and if
anything uh uh r
l
d okay
i'll do a shorter one for you rld got it
got it thanks doc we appreciate you
stopping by we will not have you back um
thank you very much everyone stick
around right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
years
bomb
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
uh welcome back
30 minutes
nut back dog
i think that'd be enough here on the
joining michael's bucket
oh
i really want to break down
thank you dr nutsac i mean newt sock
newt suck
um
uh for coming on the show and and giving
us the the breakdown
of red lighting your your your testies
seems like a testy festy to me when
you're shining a light on your balls i
don't know is it really surprising that
these these alpha cuck
tucker
anti-mass types
are french frying their nut sacks is it
really that surprising it shouldn't be
that surprising that this is what
they're doing now as uh everyone knows
uh
testicular testy testy tanning is
trending on
uh twitter this morning
and the reason why is because of this
clip right here let me uh let me make
this a little bigger so you can see um
this may or may not be the doctor that
just came on that was has the degree
from herverd university down in alabama
where he
graduated summa come loud but let's
let's listen to what him and tucker
carlson talk about french frying french
frying your ballsack let's listen you
saw in the clip there um if you want to
optimize and take it uh to another level
expose yourself to red light therapy yes
and the juve um that we were using in
the documentary he said the juve
since then that's the vernacular i guess
i don't know
there's a massive amount of testicle
tanning testicle tanning which is
testicle tanning like literally when you
say it out loud
tucker
you said it out loud here's the putin
propaganda network
right
abandoning their putin propaganda
to talk about how men aren't manly
i'm gonna break down what the [ __ ] that
means and what they're trying to say in
the tropes they're trying to say but
more importantly what fox news and
tucker carlson are trying to do here
ultimately to their audience testicle
tanning but it's also full body uh red
light therapy which has massive amount
of benefits and there's so much data out
there um there's so much data out there
on the internet you know you just put it
up on the internet and then it's there
that doesn't mean
so obviously half the viewers right now
are like what that's quite escalating
that's crazy no not half the viewers all
of them
all of them but the ones that are
already tanning their testicles
are going what in the [ __ ] are you
talking about
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
tanning your testicles now here's the
thing
a lot of [ __ ] idiots watch this show
and we're like testicle tanning that
makes you more manly well
let's tan them up bros
just christ but my view is okay
testosterone levels crash and nobody
says anything about it that's crazy
testosterone level levels are not
crashing that is such [ __ ] stupid ass
[ __ ] that's such stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] now an army our argument could
be made that testosterone levels are
lower now for a lot of different reasons
but they're not crashing this is really
dumb
and this is really [ __ ] stupid to
think that your testosterone levels are
the thing that make you manly tucker
carlson and these [ __ ] alpha cup
types are [ __ ] stupid
your testosterone levels and how much
you can lift at the gym has nothing to
do with you being manly
go ask anyone who knows anything about
being attracted to a manly man okay it
has nothing to do with it not a god damn
thing
this is all a [ __ ] trope of gay men
can't be manly and manly men can't be
gay if you're insecure about your
sexuality and your homosexual tendencies
out there this is tucker carlson
speaking to his listeners
if you are insecure about your sexuality
and your homosexual tendencies my
audience have no fear
because if you're a manly man and you
tan your balls
then you must not be gay so don't listen
to those little whispers inside your
head
this is all really [ __ ] stupid this
is the same nonsense and the same
dribble where [ __ ] men get their
[ __ ] butt hurt because a trans woman
goes into a bathroom to take a leak
they're so [ __ ] obsessed obsessed
with genitalia it's [ __ ] weird and
gross
but the reason why is it's because
of their insecurities their and they're
terrified of sexuality
terrified of sexuality
but it's because of their insecurities
of their homosexual tendencies here's
what i'm talking about you want to know
what i'm talking about dude goes to a
gym
sees a bunch of other dudes lifting
weights
sweaty muscular really pumping the iron
right
oh man i want to look like him he's sexy
deep down inside he says whoa well that
must be that must be a homosexual
tendency so they get a little frightened
right they get frightened because
they're terrified of sexuality the other
thing is they're terrified of someone
knowing that they might find a dude sexy
my god his body's sexy
and that makes him gay and the only way
to not be gay is to have more
testosterone
it's all a [ __ ] trope the whole
[ __ ] show the whole [ __ ] thing
it's a trope that if you're a manly man
you can't be gay and if you're gay you
can't be a manly man it's really [ __ ]
dumb
it's really [ __ ] dumb because here's
the here's the bottom line
the tucker carlson tucker carlson
couldn't handle a manly man he couldn't
because he's a little whiny [ __ ]
tucker carlson is and all this is is
more [ __ ] disputed their audience to
do the whole tucker carlson's trying out
joe rogan joe rogan here
to make it to where non-experts who
don't know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about who have no idea what they're
saying
and don't give a [ __ ] about actual
studying actual science to try to prove
something is or isn't true
to just spew their garbage and make them
into experts just like joe rogan does on
his show
it's the same [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
anti-basque anti-mask anti-backs type
[ __ ] same [ __ ] same
[ __ ]
oh you get well [ __ ] if you just
exercise
then you'll you'll fend off disease well
being healthy
helps if you get a disease
but being healthy doesn't prevent you
from getting a disease you dumb
[ __ ]
being healthy doesn't prevent your
testosterone levels from dropping
there's a whole hell of a host of
reasons why a dude's testosterone levels
would drop
and the best solution
i'm not a doctor
i'm not but i would go seek advice to a
doctor who knows something about
testosterone before you start french
frying your nut sac
and really honestly i bet the doctor's
gonna prescribe you i don't know if you
have low t testosterone
it really is [ __ ] dumb
but the point of all this this whole
documentary all this [ __ ]
it's just
just an anti-gay trope that if you're
gay you're not manly and trust me manly
men out there
don't just ignore your homosexual
tendencies because if you're manly
you must not be gay
really is
more than trudging out
of their anti-lgbtq
agenda
i hate gay people
i don't want gay people
and they're terrified
terrified
of their own homosexual tendencies
terrified of them
can't get past them
um there was some more video from the
tucker carlson documentary let's see if
we can
pull it up here
uh because there's some other [ __ ]
that they're talking about and again
it's more proof that
that uh um
tucker carlson is trying to out joe
rogan joe rogan here is the opening
scene
from the uh here's the trailer from the
tucker carlson uh gay porn ad
viagra and i don't know what the [ __ ]
this is
you talk about people really
getting entrenched in their
insecurities of their homosexual
tendencies watch this
[Music]
this this is the uh this is the part
where the guy was talking about
uh the the i don't know what the hell he
called the jube the jube or some [ __ ]
this is where they're actually redlining
their balls you see this dude standing
here naked uh with the red line on his
nut sack now again
i'm just telling you if you don't know
anything about the male genitalia
there's this thing that hangs over and
really honestly if you're going to
really red light your nut sack
mike
i'm just i'm just saying
you know
just saying
you tuck up the sausage is what i'm
saying
once the society collapses then
you're in hard times well
hard iron sharpens iron as they say and
those hard times inevitably
produce men who are tough men who are
resourceful men who
are strong enough to survive
this is really stupid this is really
stupid
really [ __ ] stupid okay let's let's
go i want to show you another video
that's the trailer here but um
um let's see if there's
the video
um the other two bearded guys talking
about butchering animals and how aliens
i'm not [ __ ] you they went into
extraterrestrials
aliens they were talking about [ __ ]
aliens
this is not made up
uh let me see if i can find it here
of course
it's not gonna be easy to find
because it's buried
great
well you're just gonna have to believe
me on this one there was two guys called
the bearded butchers
on this show and they were giving their
expert advice
on how butchering animals were
extraterrestrials butchering animals or
some dumb [ __ ] i don't know
okay let's go to the trendy trends and
tweety tweets i want to get back to the
the alex jones um
um
before we before we kick out here we're
15 minutes into the second hour
i don't want to miss this this is not
this is not
um
a a headline that we should miss radio
host alex jones company infowar files
for bankruptcy following lawsuits by
parents killed in the sandy hook
shooting numb as you know the sandy hook
parents have won their lawsuit their
defamation lawsuit against alex jones
and infowars
they're going to have to he's going to
have to pay up the court's going to
order him to pay now what alex jones is
doing here is alex jones is using
chapter 11 laws in the state of texas
to try to fend off this debtor to
restructure okay so what happens with
with the businesses and rich people the
privilege that they get it is a
privilege
if you don't if you out there don't know
you have it
here's what here's what's here's what's
happening because a lot of people are
saying that
alex jones is pretending to be broke
which that's essentially kind of what
chapter 11 is
i'm not a lawyer i'm not a bankruptcy
lawyer i'm not an accountant
but when you go file chapter 11 it's to
it's to make sure you keep your company
the thing that is making you profit
right
and your your argument to the court is
hey judge
if you make me pay this entire debt
which would be the lawsuit
if you make me pay this entire debt
then i will be broke we will not we will
be bankrupt we will not be able to
survive which [ __ ] him that's the way it
should be but
he's filing chapter 11. so what he's
asking the court to do
is to legally restructure the debt so he
has to pay it over a certain period of
time based on the profit that his
company would have
that's what's happening
so in other words
alex jones is not saying is his company
is bankrupt he's saying if he has to pay
the debt of the lawsuit that was won by
the parents of sandy hook he would be
bankrupt
that debt
would bankrupt him
so he's asking the court to restructure
that debt so that his business infowars
and a couple other businesses
can stay in operation
and that's the [ __ ] thing here
really and uh you know honestly the the
sandy hook parents i think could
probably give a [ __ ] less about the
money i don't think this this whole
thing
with the defamation had nothing to do
with the money they could give a [ __ ]
less
about the money but at the point of uh
of trying to damage alex jones for the
defamation that he and um
so ensued on them and they had to incur
the defamation for years
that the sandy hook shooting was staged
and all this nonsense after their
children was killed because i i would
doubt that any amount of money
any amount of money would be
sufficient for those parents
in this situation where their children
were [ __ ] slaughtered
by a by a person who got their hands on
a semi-automatic rifle and mowed them
down
i would highly doubt that any amount of
money would satisfy them at this point
and it doesn't matter who the [ __ ]
money would come from
i would say that they would not be happy
at that with any amount of money
but
having said that
and i think the goal here is to punish
alex jones
and to punish infowars for what they
did not not not by causing sandy hook
but but causing them more heartache and
more grief
and more personal injury throughout the
years
propagating the lie
that sandy hook was somehow staged
so the only way to punish alex jones or
infowars is to take him to court and
punish them financially
and use the courts
and some sort of decision to do that i
don't [ __ ] blame him and i would keep
going after him until his company's gone
but just like those sandy hook parents
are using the courts
to try to punish alex jones for what
they what he has done to them by
defaming them and slandering them
and causing their heartache and pain and
suffering to continue
by having his fans
continually broad them with [ __ ]
because of his [ __ ] lies
now
alex jones is using the court in the
same way to try to save his ass
i don't know if it's right wrong or
indifferent but it's a privilege that is
awarded to rich people corporations and
white folk in this country
so if you want to know the full truth
and nothing but the truth here it is
alex jones and infowars are despicable
vile pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ]
and in this country people should be
smart enough
to know that that freedom of speech that
he propagates over there on empty wars
is a bunch of god damn horseshit
but we're not smart enough we're not
educated enough
we're not we're just not we're just not
there in this country in this time in
this place
because of that alex jones continues to
propagate and profit off his nonsense
and because he continues to profit off
his nonsense and he makes
bucket loads of money from these [ __ ]
fools who believe this garbage
he's gonna try to file chapter 11 and
and protect his profit machine that is
infowars and he's going to try to
restructure the debt to where he can
continue in operation with infowars and
whatever companies he has and still
comply with the lawsuit
and the debt as it were for the payment
that he has been ordered to pay the
sandy hook parents
so
if
if you're wondering why alex jones is
doing this it's not because he is broke
it's because he would be
if he had to pay this court-ordered
payment
but in this country in this great
country of capitalism and
america the privilege that is awarded to
rich folk rich white folk especially in
texas they can fire chapter 11
bankruptcy and structure their debt to
where they can remain profitable
and guys it's not because it's not
because he sells a product it's because
people buy his [ __ ]
the problem is not alex jones
the problem is not freedom of speech
the problem is the american public is
[ __ ] dumb
they're [ __ ] dumb
we have to get we have to get better at
education and the right wing knows this
and they're taking advantage of it jesus
christ they're banning math in florida
they're banning math because critical
race theory you know
critical race theory they're gonna make
your white children feel guilty about
their arithmetic
i don't know i don't i can't understand
how this even [ __ ] makes sense i
don't know if they're like two black
people plus two black people these are
four black people that's critical race
theory
i don't know how they're even get
getting to this point but they're trying
to ban arithmetic folks
the reason why is because they want this
man alex jones to be the smartest guy in
the room
so should you be pissed off this morning
about the bankruptcy
of infowars certainly you should be
pissed off that alex jones
has the ability to use the court
to continue
to propagate his lies and use his
privilege to do so
certainly you should be pissed off
let me tell you something about him
filing bankruptcy
alex jones's only choice to stay
profitable
is to file bankruptcy he's pretending to
be broke
so that way a judge will grant him the
right
to continue his profiteering off his
propaganda
now whether a judge grants that or not
that's up to a judge rather a judge will
restructure his debt or not that's up to
a judge the judge could tell him to go
[ __ ] himself that you cannot restructure
this debt into chapter 11.
it is a court system folks
so it's not like you just get to fill
out a little paper and all of a sudden
you're bankrupt and you get to
restructure your debt
a judge gets to decide and a judge could
decide to make him [ __ ]
squeeze him so goddamn hard that there's
barely enough profit to even live off of
so we'll see we'll see what comes out of
the bankruptcy court we'll find out
as alex jones and infowars hopefully
is broken to oblivion
nothing better for this country okay
let's go back to the trinity trends and
the tweety tweets now we know
uh let's see here
as a german
is uh trending and the reason why is
because
this person here
um
looks like a resistor and tweeted a
photo of kyle rittenhouse
the murderer that he is right before he
committed the murders
as a german i never understood how the
earth how on earth this kid could walk
around
on open street with a gun
because in germany you can't do that by
the way um but it really pissed off the
right wing they're [ __ ] infuriated
as a german as a german as a german oh
don't say as a german they're pissed off
about this you should go in this thread
and read this thread
and we're 25 minutes in the hour i have
several things i want to get to to here
so we won't be able to go into that
there but you really should go into that
thread
and check that out uh common core here
is the um
here's governor the the
bigoted nazi down in uh uh florida
trying to ban
trying to ban arithmetic
florida officials have blocked 54 math
textbooks from k-12 curriculum claiming
some of them contain critical race
theory
oh my god
i i don't i don't get how people aren't
[ __ ] understanding that they're not
gonna stop they're not gonna stop with
this [ __ ]
they're not gonna quit folks
oh well they're just gonna do the crt
thing when it comes to history
ah well they're just gonna take women's
liberty away they're not actually going
to take away other people oh they're
going to take lgbtq uh people's liberty
away too oh okay oh they want to take
black people's liberty away oh okay take
away the right to vote oh okay well you
know they won't come for me
they won't come for me they're coming
for you they're coming for your children
they want full consent over your
children they want full consent they
want full consent over their education
they want to marry
your children doubt me
passing laws
to ban math because of critical race
theory they really are off the [ __ ]
rails folks but this is what fascism
does
they're really [ __ ] desperate here
they're extremely desperate
people aren't canceling their disney
plus subscriptions
it's a problem that they see
the rejected titles make up a record 41
percent of books submitted for review
jesus christ
npr's reporting here
54 math books
50
[ __ ]
four
a war on arithmetic
it really is getting ridiculous
of course um
common core is is um
is trending maybe that's how they're
calling this critical race theory i have
no idea
i have no idea why they're calling this
the arithmetic has anything to do with
critical race theory let's see what u.s
singers as i say usa singer says
republicans hate cancer culture except
for common core math
history science books teachers schools
voting rights disney sesame street dr
seuss mr potato head women's rights the
lgbt community truth justice diversity
separation church estate and democracy
they hate cancer culture all but those
things that are actual cancel culture
who wants to hear let's see if we can
find is there an explanation on video of
this like someone actually standing up
and explaining this [ __ ]
of how [ __ ] math common core math
is somehow tied to critical race theory
do we yet have video let's go to videos
here let's see
is there yet video of ron desantis
trying to explain to us
how critical race theory has anything to
do with math
let's see i don't see one not you know
i guess that's indicative of of this
charade that they're putting on is that
they can't even get in front of a camera
and let folks know down in florida why
math why math is racist
oh jesus
we really we really are and i don't know
if it's because maybe it's because
common core um was put into place by
obama maybe that's why it's critical
race theory i don't know
everyone everyone thinks that it's
that liberals
and people on the left
are way out of control when they're
talking about
critical rate series voodoo
if you didn't realize that it was voodoo
before you should realize that it's now
and i don't know why we can't get our
[ __ ] act together and all get on the
same page
about trying to tell parents about
critical race theory and how it's all
[ __ ] it has been will be always will
be [ __ ] when it comes to your
[ __ ] kindergartners and by the way
not
not being able to say gay in an
elementary school
is also detrimental to your
kindergartners that's right it's
detrimental
common core cancel culture against
common core math
this is where we're at let's see what
else do we have training is there
anything new trending
everyone's wanting me to play a video in
the chat
what video do you want me to play
now
i see
they want the alex jones video
all right all right all right
hang on a second let's let's um
let's get the alex jones everyone wants
the alex jones video to come up here
you ready here it is
[Music]
[Music]
they literally crawl out from
[Music]
i have them on video
[Music]
in the creepy weird sixth man
okay so i i know you don't want me to
stop this right in the middle of this
great song but here's the thing here's
the thing about this don't you see the
projection here don't you see it i i
don't understand how how people haven't
seen the projection from the right here
yeah let's continue
she sleeps in the same room
[Music]
imagine how bad she smells man
i'm told her and obama just stink
obama and hillary both smell like sofa
[Music]
[Music]
my spirit gets close to that evil and i
feel like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
son
[Music]
oh well thank you very much for making
me
[Music]
i'm sure everyone's just uh oh my god
oh for crying out loud no
let's get back to regular business here
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you robin for
um
oh my god
oh
[ __ ]
okay well um that is a great song
um here's the thing here's the thing
that chris says what the [ __ ] was that
here's here's what that was those are
actual words that that alex jones said
into a microphone they were just put to
a great song so all those words that you
heard that was a song
um the lyrics were written by alex jones
of the crazy [ __ ] that he says into a
microphone and we're standing around
wondering why they're banning math books
down in florida
they think there's lizard people out
there
who are propagating common core on your
children
to make sure that critical race theory
makes white white children feel guilty i
don't [ __ ] know if you figure it out
email me
[ __ ] in christ these people are still
searching for hunter biden's laptop when
jared kushner
takes two billion dollars from prince
bone saul over in saudi arabia
you make it make [ __ ] sense with
these hunter biden laptop nazis i don't
know what to tell you it's a q anon
world out there we're just [ __ ]
living in it folks
and that's why that's why we have to get
our messaging straight we're not going
to be able to talk these people down
from the q and on ledge you're not
you're not going to be able to talk them
down from the q anon ledge but people
out there who are concerned about [ __ ]
you gotta convince them that these crazy
[ __ ] that are standing up on the q and
on ledge
you want the people trying to marry your
children and ban their [ __ ] math test
do you want those people
controlling your gas prices do you want
them to control your health benefits
do you want these people really passing
legislation in your state
to help you not to vote is that what you
want you want these fascists who were
banning math in florida
they're banning math books folks
they're banning arithmetic
in florida
it's absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
texas is trying out florida florida
florida's trying out texas texas
in tennessee standing back saying hold
my beer we're gonna marry children
i want to show you a video speaking of
uh
bigoted [ __ ] laws
i want to show you a video here let me
find it here
a lawmaker in my great state of missouri
you guys seen it go viral over the
weekend
his name is ian mackey
missouri's trying to do the [ __ ]
bigoted laws just like everywhere else
in the country
yes that's right missouri is trying to
outflow to florida and trying out texas
texas too
it's happening here just like it's
happening in all these other red states
you've seen you've seen also over the
weekend um k ivy down in alabama
with her with her [ __ ]
uh campaign ads it's [ __ ] gross
but that's what they're doing
uh
dude i'm still looking for it here give
me just a second i will find this video
it is uh absolutely fantastic what ian
mackey does here we go
again um in the stadium in the state of
missouri
the missouri
republicans the pedocon kid diddlers are
trying to take consent away from parents
about their children
by doing it through a trans athlete bill
literally this affects maybe
maybe three or four children in the
entire state of missouri
this bill
that they're spending their time in the
missouri legislature legislating three
people in the entire [ __ ] state but
that's not what they're actually
legislating folks
you have to take them
and face value they want to gradually
take your consent away from you and give
it to the state
for your children and their bodies
they want their minds they want their
bodies so they can marry them i'm not
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
this is [ __ ] real
yeah oh tony it has to do with men and
women sports no it does not there are
not men
in women's sports
they're trying to prevent
a couple
people in the state children they're
trying to prevent a couple children in
the state to participate in sports is
what they're trying to do with these
bills the ultimate thing that they're
trying to do is take away consent away
from the parents and giving it to the
state
you know the old big government trope
the old big government [ __ ] that's
what they're trying to do
it has nothing to do
with sports it does not do with girls
sports it has not a goddamn thing to do
with men in girls sports
they want to take your consent as the
state
because when they develop this fascist
state when they do take over this is
their thinking when we do take over we
want to make sure the state has as much
power as we possibly can to create a
handmaid's tale we want to make sure
women have no liberty don't doubt me you
think they're just going to stop at your
[ __ ] uterus they're gonna take your
[ __ ] vote away too you watch hide and
watch they're gonna start passing laws
to take away your right to vote because
you're a woman
doubt me
do it i dare you i dare you to not
participate in our democracy i dare you
to not know what these [ __ ] fascists
are trying to do
this bill in missouri has nothing to do
about trans athletes in missouri not a
goddamn thing it has to do with taking
parents consent away from them about
their children
and ian mackey here a representative
from the state of missouri
is having [ __ ] none of it
listen to what he has to say
do you remember your remarks on the
floor last year when you brought this up
um it would you'd have to give me a
specific i mean i made a lot of remarks
sure so i recall a story you told
about your brother
and i remember you said that your
brother called or that your mother
called you i believe
to tell you that your brother had some
news
that he was afraid to tell you
okay
and your brother
wanted to tell you that he was gay
didn't he
um he was uh expressing that to the
family and he thought that
that we would hold that against him and
not let my children be around him
why do you think he thought that
i i don't know i it never would have
happened i'll tell you that
my
my my kids at that that point in their
life adored my my brother
can i tell you if i were your brother
i would have been afraid to tell you too
well i would have been afraid to tell
you too because of stuff like this
because this is what you're focused on
this is the legislation you want to put
forward this is what consumes your time
i would have been afraid to tell you too
i was afraid of people like you growing
up and i grew up in hickory county
missouri i grew up in a school district
that would vote tomorrow to put this in
place
and for 18 years
i walked around with nice people like
you
[Music]
who took me to ball games
who told me how smart i was
and they went to the ballot and voted
for crap like this
i couldn't wait to get out
i couldn't wait to move to a part of our
state
that would reject this stuff in a minute
i couldn't wait
and thank god i made it
thank god i made it out and i think
every day
of the kids who are still there
who haven't made it out who haven't
escaped
from this kind of bigotry
i want you to listen very carefully to
what in mackie says here at the end pay
a lot of attention to what he says this
is very [ __ ] important to all you
pro-democracy people out there
understand what he's saying listen
[Music]
gentlemen i'm not afraid of you anymore
because you're gonna lose you may win
this today but you're going to lose
that's very important at the end
i'm not afraid of you anymore
not [ __ ] afraid of you any more
we know who you are you're saying the
quiet part out loud you are [ __ ]
bigots
you're racist
you're privileged white men who want
power and power
alone not just not just power
but power over women
power over people power over children
power over the others because you are
fascist
and as in mackie says you may win this
right here you may win this little fight
that you want to fight right here and
right now
but in the end
in the end fascism
will lose
you're being exposed for who you are
we know who you are and we're not afraid
of you
and that is the messaging that democrats
need to carry around the entire country
give me a [ __ ] break about this
canceling student debt [ __ ]
give me a [ __ ] break about worrying
about the january 6 select committee and
what merrick garland's doing
there are fascists
everywhere in your state legislator in
your city council in your county
commission
sitting at sitting
in the united states house of
representatives and then the united
states senate
who want to take away your liberty who
want to take away your democracy
full
stop
ian mackey here
is a hero for standing up and saying
what he said
he's a [ __ ] hero
and we should praise him and play this
video this video has 5.2 million views
right here on twitter
you can see it here
it's from the missouri house democratic
caucus 5.2 million views
this video should have a billion views
any person who believes that our country
is still a democracy
and who still wants our country to be a
democracy should watch this video
and watch ian mackey destroy fascism in
a matter of two minutes
and why it is so important that we must
not look away
i say that so many times here on this
show
we cannot
we cannot look away folks
you can't just bury your head in the
sand while they take women's liberty
away from them
today it's their body tomorrow it's
their vote
you can't just stand
by and let them take
the black community's vote away from
them in these states strategically we
cannot
we can't just forget about it
we cannot stand by while these fascists
try to take away consent from parents of
their children
we cannot just stand by
this is the hill they want to die on
they want to die on the hill of fascism
folks that's where they that's where
they're going to fight
they're going to fight to ostracize the
lgbt community they're going to fight to
ban your kids math books because it
educates them they want to sexualize
your kid's gender in schools
they want to marry
your children
if you're not paying attention there are
bills all around the country
sprouting up
in the guise of anti-gay marriage bills
and making it to where there's no age
limit to where white men can marry your
little girls and don't get it twisted
that's
what they're doing
you think we're not too [ __ ] steps
away from handmaid's tale that's what
they want
that's what they want
today they don't want you reading about
real history
because it it might it might make white
parents feel guilty
tomorrow they don't want you to learn
arithmetic that way you can't count how
many kids you got left because the white
dude down the street who has all the
power has married them all
it's not complicated folks
it's not complicated how we win the 2022
midterms i don't sit here every day for
two hours noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch
and now on the facebook page i might as
touch i don't sit here for two hours
yelling into this microphone for no
goddamn reason
the reason is to give you the messaging
the reason is to give you the way to go
out there and talk to your community
members
talk to your brothers your sisters the
people at your church the people at your
school
folks
not a goddamn person that you interact
with at your school understands that in
florida they're trying to ban arithmetic
they don't understand it they don't get
it they're worried about the baseball
score this afternoon
they're worried about who's gonna play
on this football team next season
who signed what contract
they're worried about their reality show
on thursday who's gonna win who's
getting voted off the island
there are single moms out there that
have three kids and two jobs
and trying to find a third one to keep
her family fed
you think she has time you think she has
time to pay attention to politics in
this country
do you think
we have to get our messaging straight
and we can win 2022 folks
oh my god can we win it
they want to fight the culture wars
you think people you think the marginal
vote the generic ballot as it were you
guys know we have rachel bittikoffer on
here a political strategist and she
talks about the generic ballot
which everyone sees as moderates or the
independent vote but really it's people
who don't know much about politics but
do vote
that generic ballot is the ballot that
always swings
and they swing based on what is the
forefront of their minds
what's at the forefront what in politics
concerns them
on the generic ballot
and who is the person and who is the
party
that most scares the ever loving bejesus
out of them you go and you look at any
republican ad right now go look at any
of them i don't care which one you look
at every single one of them are talking
about how
liberals are going to teach your kids
crt
how how
men are going to participate in women's
sports
they're not fighting each other folks
they're not running ads against each
other they're running ads
against this fake deep state radical
socialist commie
nonsense this q a nonsense
and it's a winning strategy
it's a winning strategy if it doesn't
terrify the absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
you
it should
it should
that's the strategy that they're going
to use and it works
it [ __ ] works do you know what
doesn't work you know what doesn't work
talking about canceling student debt
that's not gonna work
you think a bunch of people who are on
the generic ballot are gonna go
oh my god they're trying to destroy my
kids education
but there's this guy over here that
wants to you know cancel student net
oh well you know
i'll vote for no they're not nope nope
we gotta tell them the truth about what
they're actually trying to do to your
children
we gotta tell them the truth what
they're trying to do to your liberty
that's what we have to do
we can we can handle the student debt
thing
as long as they're not in pow you think
the people who are banning arithmetic in
florida
are going to be for canceling students
that you won't even have a university to
go to
they don't even want schools
they want indoctrination centers they
want re-education camps folks
you think you're gonna have student debt
when these fascists take over
[Laughter]
uh you're not gonna be getting educated
you're gonna be getting indoctrinated
when these fascists take over that's the
whole point
doubt me
um
the representative that
um ended up
ian mackie hear [ __ ] all over um he did
have a response let's see if i can if i
can pull it up real quick what his
response on like twitter or something
was and i don't know if anyone posted it
here
i don't have it handy he basically said
he and mackie made a fool out of me and
i'm i'm really upset that he did that
i'm really upset that he made a fool out
of me and i'm pissed off
i'm really pissed off and i got a really
a bunch of stupid [ __ ] comments
from a bunch of [ __ ] uh white dudes
like oh
he and mackie being upset because he's
gay has nothing to do with what this
bill is this bill is trying to prevent
men from playing in women's sports
that's not it at all
it's preventing children participating
in activities at school
and making it to where schools can be
bigoted
and be bigoted against kids who want to
participate in sports
it's really [ __ ] dumb they're
children they're [ __ ] children
they're not professional athletes
they're not doing this for profit it's
[ __ ] children
um let's see if i can find thee
[Music]
oh you know what
speaking of rachel bittegover she was on
uh joanne reed show and she's talking
about what i was just talking about
listen listen to what rachel says here
about the 15-week abortion ban speaking
speaking of cancel culture in florida
and that nazi bigot
ron desantis he wants to take away
women's right to choose too ah who would
have thought it i bet i bet his next his
his next mission is to take away the
right to vote so that way they can't
vote him out let's see what rachel has
to say let me ask a question because
it's all cool until the bodies start
being shown and i've worked in local
news you have some teenage rape victims
that are dying because they tried to get
you do a self-abortion you know and take
too many of whatever the pills are they
get under do that underground and refuse
to go to the clinic because it's illegal
and they're scared it's all cool until
people start dying and good luck trying
to hide that ask vladimir putin how that
works out i want to ask you rachel a bit
of coffer whether or not this has been a
good issue because abortion was legal
now that it's going to be illegal across
these red states what happens
because white women let's just be clear
have voted majority republicans since
the 1960s it's been very solid even when
there's a woman on the ballot often
right
but what happens to that vote do you see
that vote starting to get shaky when
their daughters are the ones who are in
the crosshairs of this when they're
sisters do you see them moving
somewhat off the team
if you start to see this the the bodies
the people starting to die or suffer
and you don't even need to wait till
that moment happens right because here's
the thing abortion politics over the
course of the 90s through the 2000s it
benefited them they coin i mean they're
so good at rhetoric right they coined
the pro-life movement that really
started to define abortion you saw a
small erosion in access support from
that effort right but you know now the
politics are the opposite we're under a
five alarm fire there's no need to wait
until somebody actually dies what you
have to do is paint a picture for the
electorate of what's coming and
especially in these like i mean there's
a lot of different targets and ads that
should go out to this community to
people who would be sensitive to this
but the one that i really want to see
run is in suburban america letting these
mothers know of all races white women
and all um what will happen if they try
to outsource an abortion out of state
they are going to jail that is what
these laws are having in provisions so
that it is true it will be inequitable
poor people always suffer from
restriction to abortion um but at the
end of the day
their goal is to is to control women
right and they're not leaving a loophole
for white educated suburbanites that's
correct they're gonna they want to
control all women
and that is that's the that's the main
point there that they want to control
all women
they want to control their bodies they
want to control what states they go to
they're going to come after your vote
that's what's next
because they don't want you to vote them
out
you say oh tony that's ridiculous you're
being you're being way out of hand oh
come on it can't be that bull [ __ ]
[ __ ] it can't
they're doing it they're doing it in
georgia they're doing it in texas
they're gerrymandering all over the
place to take people of color's vote
away from them
you don't think they'll come for the
women's vote too come on
come on they know they can't get rid of
abortion abortion isn't the thing you
get rid of
abortion is a thing you criminalize
you make you make poor women into felons
because let's face it abortion's never
been illegal for rich people in this
country
never
never
abortion has never listened to what i
say
abortion has never been illegal for rich
people in this country
rich people can afford abortions and
they can afford to hide it
and that will be the case when you don't
make it
the ability for women to have their
liberty and make their own medical
decisions
about their [ __ ] bodies
and dudes out there hey you dudes out
there
you [ __ ] dudes out there
they're coming for you next you dumb
[ __ ] if you think if you think
these fascists are gonna stop at women
and people of color and the lgbtq
community you are a dumb son of a [ __ ]
tucker carlson has got the writing all
over the wall
there is gonna be a testosterone
borderline
that they're gonna have
do you don't think you don't think
tucker carlson isn't gonna float in the
next couple months maybe we should have
a testosterone test to see who's liberal
or not
that's what they're saying
that's that's what they're saying
that's all the nonsense that they're
spewing that's how fascism works that's
how it takes hold little by little by
little by little by little
they take women's liberty away here they
take lgbt communities liberty away there
they take the trans children's
liberty here they take the parents
consent from from their from their
children's
gender identity here they sexualize your
kids gender in kindergarten here and
then they want to marry him here in
tennessee and then they might want to
marry him in missouri and then they take
your consent away from you to let let
rich powerful white men marry your
children
they take over your state here they take
over your state there
i'm telling you folks
pay the [ __ ] attention and get the
messaging right
get the messaging right
tell your people in your community at
your churches your schools your
community centers your [ __ ] grocery
store for crying out loud
just ask
just ask the next time you go on a
grocery ask the person checking out
groceries just ask them this question
did you hear their banning math in
florida
just ask them that question real simple
did you hear
did you hear that they're banning math
in florida
and just see what they say
they're going to say no i hadn't heard
that what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding me they're trying to ban math
why is that why are they trying to ban
math
that's what they're going to say
and that's when you gotta have you gotta
have it queued up because the fascists
like ron desantis and the republicans
not only want to ban math they want to
ban school altogether they don't want
your kids to be educated they want to
send them indoctrination camps where
they can marry them once they're done at
12.
i mean your daughters they're not going
to marry men off to grown women they're
not going to marry little boys off to
grown women they don't want to you know
take away that little boy's manhood for
him to grow up to be a man to marry a
little 12 year old boy girl again
these [ __ ] sick [ __ ]
don't quit don't stop
we can do this too we can win 2022 we
can kick him out of government we can
kick the pedo con republican kid
diddlers out of government and take back
control and have some common sense
[ __ ] policy some common sense [ __ ]
goals
in this country and do the democracy
thing
and then speaking of democracy and doing
democracy
join me tomorrow
a lot of ball talk this morning and
doing democracy oh [ __ ] we're in trouble
folks
until tomorrow we'll do democracy
tomorrow folks let's do democracy
tomorrow noon eastern 11 center right
here on youtube twitter twitch don't
forget to go to youtube
search the tony michaels podcast
subscribe to the youtube channel join us
on midas touch facebook page
on the books of face tomorrow
every single weekday monday through
friday
and until tomorrow surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking